Let me go next to.
Hold on a second.
Let's go to Kevin from New York.
Kevin from New York.
What's on your mind today?
Oh, holy crap.
I'm talking to Dave Akerman right now.
You're on right now, my friend.
I'm a big fan.
Thank you, sir.
It's a couple like two weeks ago, I was talking
to my my friend talking politics, my friend.
Yeah.
And he opposes.
That was the worst walk lockdown's because.
Because because they lose because of the whole
business and jobs losing their businesses
and jobs, right.
And whereas your friend Liv.
I want to stay in anonymous, OK?
Can you tell me what state your friend lives
in?
I'm not sure.
He hasn't told me.
I just want to stay anonymous.
Wait a second.
You have a friend and you don't know what
state they live in.
That's very interesting.
That's or friend.
He's a Dysport friend.
OK.
I'm not aware of any state that is locked
down right now.
So if your friend lives in a different country,
then that would be interesting to know.
Either I wasn't sure what he's talking about
either.
Yeah.
So he basically, I, I, I said that we should
give money to the businesses for that.
We should give money to businesses so they
can pay their employees.
But he's like due to unemployment.
But he's like no cause I'll start the Roth.
But because that's why people are rioting
where he says people are rioting when businesses
get money for employees.
And he opposes unemployment benefits because
of that.
Your friend doesn't strike me as that bright.
That's what I'm good at.
That's my only thought.
Yeah.
Yeah, sorry.
I mean, I'm kind of nervous because I'm speaking
to you.
You're doing great.
Oh, OK.
Yeah.
All right, very good.
I don't I don't know that I would argue with
that friend.
I would spend my time doing something more
productive.
This friend doesn't sound like they're making
any sense.
Yeah.
But what do you think I should say?
I would say, listen, I don't even know you
or know what state you live in.
So it's I don't even know what you're talking
about.
You know, I'm gonna go talk to somebody else
on Dischord.
That's my genuine advice.
Now, have you?
No problem.
All right.
Thank you
very much.